Alright. Now this is pretty straightforward. Seeing as though the calling code
has given us an X and Y value of where to exist in the world, we simply pass
those through to the entity definition object. Next, we actually determine the
half width and the half height of the bounding box for this object. Now for the
simple projectile class that we're using here, we statically define its width
and height to five units. Of course, passing half of that to the right
variable. In addition, we also set the surface parameter of dampening to zero.
Now in order to facilitate as a debugging aid for our purposes, we pass in an
ID object to the entity definition. Now inside the addBody method, we attach
this ID properly so that later on we can identify this object differential from
everything else. This helps with debugging and determining whether it's a
missile hitting you in the forehead, or a rubber chicken.